so john cena let's talk about what
happened with john cena so john cena go
to page uh
five john cena who is loved i would say
he's adored he's admired by a lot of
people
okay wrestler movie star rock star
great physique you know he is uh in the
camp of
what would you say the rock van diesel
put some of those names there right he's
he's like
he's like rock light yeah he's rocking
when you order when you order rock on
wish.com
yeah john cena called pathetic for
apologizing to china over taiwan's
remark new york post story john cena was
on the receiving end of a
pile driver tuesday after american
twitter user
uh users after his pathetic apology to
china for referring us to
taiwan as a country during a promotional
spot for his new movie
f9 fast enough furious not cena speak in
mandarin went on the chinese social
media side weibu tuesday to apologize
for calling taiwan a country during a
promotional
interview for f9 the latest installment
for the fast and furious franchise
earlier this month the chinese who
consider taiwan a rogue province
uh that is part of their territory
erupted in outreach at his blunder
and he said the following i made one
mistake i have to say something very
very very important now i
love and respect china and chinese
people he didn't say i love and respect
chinese people he said i love and
respect
china and chinese people i'm very very
sorry about my mistake i apologize i
apologize i'm very sorry
you must understand that i really love
really respect china and the chinese
people my apologies
see you pathetic said senator tom
cotton's reaction to cena's
mia copa and by the way a bunch of other
people even keith olbermann said stuff
like what are you doing this was
pathetic
left and right all over the place they
were not happy about what this guy had
to say but what are your thoughts about
what cena said
um all right i'll go first number one
how the hell are there
nine the fast and furious movies that
was the first thing that came down
that's what you took away i can see it
the first thing that you think i'm like
alright this is f9 well
ten if you count point break which they
basically just got to say
well anyway that that's just that that's
the real issue and don't get me i
actually had a really fun night with
vandy uh vin diesel one night
that's a whole nother oh here we go fun
time fun oh here we go
number two he went to he went to
djibouti with vin diesel oh that was
some
booty believe that it was a fun night in
south beach but
um number two
um
you got to use one of those jokes on a
wednesday night the um
the fact that the guy this guy full-on
speaks mandarin yeah
so this was not some hey guy uh read
this
attempt to read it it was you've been
studying mandarin you've been realizing
that you're gonna start making money in
china yeah for the next decade
bust out that mandarin you've been
working on for the last 10 years yeah
and uh just do your little mia culpa and
actually put it to use right now
he's like okay i got this and just did
his thing
did you see what he looks like these
days my first when i when i watched that
my and i posted this too and my first
reaction was this dude's angling for
an an earnest goes to beijing reboot
like i was like what the hell
this is john cena look first of all if
anybody out there is thinking of of
doing copious amounts of steroids for
many years and growth hormone and stuff
like that john cena is proof that just
you can't ever get off of it my god
if you're in you're in forever man
because this dude looks like a wilted
leaf
let's pull up a picture have you
recently have you seen him recently my
god
look look at this picture recent picture
this dude those are all good pictures
you got to pick up the one from do
the video he looks like earnest man it's
so it's like insane the guy went from
like 30 to 55
in like a year and a half kai just go up
let's see the video his apology is it on
his instagram it's not on his instagram
dude
obviously he's not going to put that on
his instagram i'll tell you that first
story new york times just hit the first
door the big thing about this right
keep going go ahead the big thing about
this
is it's not just john cena it's the
alarming trend
that holla that hollywood is completely
owned by china
there's no no americans aren't going i
agree with you let me finish my point i
would have gone there but go ahead
i'm sorry man get take a car there
instead of a bike let's get moving
oh we're going there all right gloves
are coming off here gerard michael
watch it watch gerard michael's this
segment we know who the real mother
sucker is this
this seven minute monologue is brought
to you by the bottom line is i do agree
with you cena doesn't give two
shits about taiwan he cares about china
he cares about money and he cares about
hollywood
and he's been studying this for
obviously years to learn as a
mandarin go ahead i have your permission
yes thank you
the difference the difference between
income is 6 million versus 20 million
right so so you do a movie and you're
good with america only or the main
countries that are
you know pro-western u.s you're making
six to ten million okay maybe 15 million
but if you go u.s and you build up china
now you go from six to 10 million to 20
to 40 million it's a different payday
it's like making four movies if you just
get china for making one movie
so it's it's mathematics so that that's
that
that's worth supporting an oppressive
regime
i mean i don't know about that i don't
disagree with you i'm just telling you
that's exactly where i was going with it
daryl mori supported
democracy and free speech and you know
mao zee lebron
came out and was like shut up you don't
know what you're talking about it's like
dude
like um just imagine at some point you
have
enough money you have enough followers
you have enough views something has to
be about legacy at some point
you're gonna die you're not bringing the
money with you right
so would it put yourself in 19 now
you know i with your background i'm
sorry but i'm not trying to be you know
extremist on this but put yourself
in 1930 germany all right and
you say something about i think what uh
what these guys are doing with um
with uh minority communities and the
jews is just not right now oh oh hey
you know you don't live here how dare
you how dare you say something bad about
the
the the new regime hitler's bringing us
out of poverty you don't live here
apologize and imagine apologizing to
hitler because it's gonna double your
revenue
what the hell does that look like a
hundred years later what's your legacy
everything else you did before that does
not matter
you're hitler's [ __ ] that's all you're
going to be remembered for
john cena is xi jinping's [ __ ] he ain't
a 10 time
world champion in the wwe he's not a
movie star
the dude's a [ __ ] let me ask you say it
to his face let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question
do you think his move on what he did is
is done based on his own reasoning
or do you think i already know he had a
call with his publicist 100
he had a call with his manager number
two he had a call and here's another one
let me continue a little bit more
forget about the publicist and the
manager right if something happens
to the comedy world you may call your
manager you may call your publicist but
who else you're calling
other comedians other folks who have
dropped the ball and made me like if
billboard says what he said in one of
the jokes he did uh you know
what was it he was opening up for
oscar's academy he was doing something
and he said something offensive
yeah and he had to come i bet he's
probably calling chappelle i bet he's
probably calling john i bet he's
probably calling a few people saying hey
what the hell happened what do i do here
and someone's going to say screw them
they help with them don't let the cancer
cartridge scare the hell out of you
maybe that's on the comedy side who do
you think he called well
you think he called some well notable
names in the hollywood world and says
guys how do i handle this thing
on a much much much smaller level i told
you the
the i left my management
i i had a management company and we had
tours and everything like that
i left them because they were taking
down videos i was putting up
during the lockdown they told me what i
could and couldn't say
they told me if i continued to question
the official narrative publicly that i
was going to be taking off the tours
and i made the decision to say screw you
i'm out you don't get to tell me what i
can and can't say especially if i'm
right
especially if i'm educating myself on
the topic so do you think he spoke to
some people
i think he got i think he got bodied
like a [ __ ]
i think he let people walk him into a
corner he didn't realize he's the star
he's trying to break into this
like he wants so desperately to get into
that studio system
and it's like bro like that nobody's
gonna care
that you flexed on screen for seven
minutes in a in a in a hot wheels
commercial give another you know
another time where this has happened
give another time where this has
happened like okay
daryl mori yeah i get what happened with
houston rockets and lebron came back and
said maybe he made some emotional
comments and lebron kind of defended
you know in that one meme with lebron
went all over the place looking like
he's from china
yeah but but go back not even right now
go back 40 years ago go back 50 years
ago go back
when maryland uh marlon brando is
winning the oscar and he doesn't go up
and he sends a
you know a native american indian
actress to go receive and she gives a
speech and
go back years ago what proof is it that
this happened meaning
if today it's china who was it 40 years
ago
who was at 18 china though russia no it
wasn't china 40 years ago
mao was doing some rough stuff but there
was no no there was no profit incentive
that's what i'm saying
yeah that's what i'm saying so what i'm
trying to tell you is today
in one end on one end i fully get what's
happened with a lot of these guys
they're sitting there the manager is
saying look
i'm making 10 on 40 million or 10 on 6
million
the difference on a manager in wme or
wherever it is is what 600 000
versus 4 million at least that's the
difference between living in a
two and a half million dollar home
versus living in a 10 million home yeah
that's the difference between your
neighbor being executives in real estate
and
finance and shame difference between you
know celebrities being your neighbors
it's a different
it's a difference between being invited
to a poker party of a bunch of guys that
are doing well for themselves that no
one knows about but they're in the
business world
versus being invited to a poker party
thursday night that's basketball players
hollywood stars so you don't want to
give up that
man i'm no longer going to be invited to
that cool party the level of pressure
the level of pressure of having to be
included
in that cool party i think it's really
hurting a lot of these guys
i will tell you for me to learn a second
language
is not easy and there are a lot of
languages you can go learn that's a lot
easier than
mandarin yeah you can go learn spanish
it's easier you can go learn
french it's easier you can go learn
portuguese it's easier
you choose to learn mandarin meaning
john cena's
not a muscle head big buff dumb guy
that's not john
he's smart john is a very very smart guy
meaning
he knew when he made the decision to
take this position
he processed it he's not a dummy he's
sitting there saying
boredom so i just think there was a
level of fear from somebody that
there might be pressure from china
itself they might say what's in the
henchmen
i don't know i don't know oh my god yeah
i don't know about that i think here's
my opinion
people's liberation army is i listen i'm
from iran man and i
i i know when that happens in certain
countries and i'm not telling you that
i'm not knifed and i believe it doesn't
happen
i'm just saying i don't know it goes to
that level think about it he probably
asked himself something that you've
actually pretty much
made famous he asked himself 10 years
ago
who do you want to be who do you want to
be i want to be an action star
i want to be a movie star i don't want
to just be a wrestler i want to make
movies i want to be famous
all right what's the protocol that all
right so you got to get into hollywood
you got to start making movies you got
to be a household name
and then you got to get into bigger
markets i.e china and that's how you're
going to make your money all right who
do you
is that what you want to do yes all
right well you got to start learning
mandarin you got to start doing this you
got to start doing that
do you have a game plan in place so then
when he pisses off
taiwan you think he gives two shits
about taiwan
at no point when he said i want to be a
fighter for democracy i want to be a
freedom fighter i want to be
nelson mandela that's not who he wants
to be he wants to be a money-making
hollywood icon and this is the path to
do it
so he's sitting on that course oh wait
to be that person you don't think cena
has aspirations for politics or anything
else i have no clue if he wants to be a
politician or not
but based on this answer right here he
wants to be able to i think
i think john cena is very aspirational
well this just ruined his all his
political changes it depends it depends
how you look at it it depends which
party you're looking at i mean
for sure if you i don't care what party
it is they'll throw that
it depends you just count out to china
you're done
if you want to movie theater movie
action starts eric swallow well eric
eric sweeney left with a chinese spy and
got reelected i can give you a hundred
names
i don't think that's the route here's
where i'm going with this look the
pressures
of your long-term vision becoming a
reality the pressures of your long-term
vision become a reality
everybody goes to sleep at night
thinking about somebody as a competitor
almost if you're competitive right
michael went to sleep at night thinking
about who
you know isaac isaiah byrd
you know you can go through the list
second round was who then you had
hakeem ewing starks you know people that
got on their skin peyton these i mean
everybody went to sleep thinking about
somebody right okay
who do you think cena goes to sleep
thinking about i think it's one name the
rock
i think he thinks about the rock i don't
think he thinks about ven diesel i think
he thinks about the rug because i think
john
and rock are more similar than john and
diesel are similar i put i put john and
uh uh the rock the same
so here's a guy that cena's been in the
shadow of
the rock for a long time he's like you
know he's been in the shadow but
cena sitting there saying dude i'm a
pretty smart guy
and dude like i have a better physique
and dude i got a better
looking body and dude i'm better he in
his mind is like dude i'm better
check check check check check he's
comparing himself
yeah because when will smith when rock
went to his managers when he was first
coming up they said who do you want to
be
he said i want to be will smith but
bigger that's what he said
who said that the rock told his
management team he said i want to be
will smith but bigger
i want to be bigger than will smith but
i want to be like will smith but bigger
manager's like what are you talking
about
i just want to be like will smith by
bigger so cena you don't think he sits
in front of his managers and
says what i want to be dot dot dot
but bigger the guy's a competitive guy
so okay manager says you you want to be
that person yes here's a game plan
exactly what you just said
learn their language win the biggest
markets do this do that
and the the difference between winning
or losing china or india who do you
think it is it's china
so i don't know what's gonna happen with
this guy moving forward i do know he
lost an audience and it's tough to come
back from this
but uh i think there's more aspirations
this guy's
got that we don't know about i don't
know what that could be i think this
guy's got bigger aspirations that we
don't know but it just tells you the
power of china that china still
wants to make the world think that
taiwan is their territory
look at the power there so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye